thomas grimald thinks of himself as a
lucky guy a 35 year old stone cutter and
resident of phoenix arizona
just found new full-time work after
several months
of unemployment it was right around the
beginning of the pandemic the hours went
from 40 to 20
within two weeks i went from 20 down to
you know
almost zero at that point i did have to
quit
file the unemployment wait for that
stuff to come through
first time i ever applied for it
unemployment payments from washington
and from the state government kept him
somewhat afloat but then he fell behind
on his rent
and that had consequences despite an
arizona governor's executive order to
postpone evictions
thomas was evicted his new home now
the del rio lodge motel where he now
pays around three hundred dollars
per week now i have an eviction so now
it's going to be very hard to get a new
apartment
for ken folk president of an
organization called arizona tenants
advocates thomas case is just one of
many he is dealing with every day
the covet 19 pandemic puts people out of
work then many can't pay rent anymore
they get thrown out of their homes and
onto the streets and that in return
fuels the pandemic again
it's a no-win situation it's it's a
lose-lose situation there's there's no
um proper uh
solution here until we get a handle on
this virus
and you know especially if you've got
people out on the street
you know conveying the virus from person
to person to
social group to social group there's no
one that's going to be safe
safe is something julia brewer hasn't
felt in months she says
her husband chef was furloughed early on
in the pandemic and then got sick with
covid
she and her son were also hit by the
bike the summer was
the worst it's all of us catching
coveted
and no work everything that could go
wrong
went wrong julia has a rare neurologic
condition called stiff person syndrome
she can't work and receive social
security and disability payments
it pays the rent but that's it i have 53
dollars left
out of my social security disability
after paying rent and
it's you know crying trying to figure
out which bill is going to
be paid are we going to have enough food
left over
or am i going to have to go to the food
bank this month
julia is afraid things could even get
worse for her and her family
she has a message for washington the
three branches of government need to
come together
and make a legitimate plan for the
people
this is serious and they need to be able
to come together
on a good plan and right now
right now can't come soon enough here in
the shadows of arizona's capitol
building
in downtown phoenix this tent city for
the homeless is growing
every day
kaelicha the largest township in cape
town more than one million people live
here
including zolika velengani a month ago
she could
no longer afford the rent and simply
build her own huts on a vacant lot next
door
hundreds of others did the same and
christened the new neighborhood
covet 19.
because everything just happens because
of this covert
they were lost jobs there were nothing
for us money anything man
that's why we have to take that covert
19 name
zuleka shows us the makeshift hut where
she lives with her boyfriend and three
children
this is my house i've been staying yet
this place is too small
i've got one bed so where the children
are going to sleep you see
my house is also leaking spots
i don't have anything to solve at the
moment i don't have money
but i'm still here the family pays no
rent here
but the land doesn't belong to them
the people are setting up their shacks
all over the place a lot of construction
happening and many
are saying they don't have a choice
because they can't afford to pay rent
any longer but the city on the other
hand says these
illegal land invasions are causing huge
problems
city officials tell us there have been
more than 30 new locations with massive
land occupations
in just the last 6 weeks law and order
are in danger
cape town lost 300 hectares of land in
the last year whatever the land was
meant for is lost
whether it is a hospital a school clinic
if a piece of land is standing open it's
because there is an intended community
use for that land
there is in the case of these big
kailicha land invasions where i will
tell you that community leadership in
kylie just stood up
this is not a fight against land
invaders against the state
or land invaders against the city of
cape town this is the fight of land
invaders against the city of cape town
and local residents
since june the city says it has torn
down some sixty thousand huts
in some cases resulting in violence this
man was pulled out of his hut
naked a court has now ruled that the
city needs a court order for evictions
and must offer alternative accommodation
to squatters
structures but the city can't afford
that 400
000 people are already on waiting lists
for social housing
that housing waiting this doesn't get
shorter and the reason it doesn't get
shorter
is because there's constantly people
pushing in the front if you were
standing in a queue in a bank
or at a cinema or theater or something
and you never got to the front because
people were constantly pushing in the
front you would become very angry and
enraged
have also been hoping for an apartment
from the state for a long time
so far in vain the governor should
provide
us our needs because we need something
like toilets
or water electricity we have to care we
have to get them from the government
it's our rightmost if we have to live in
this place
we have
because when we need to go to the loo or
you want to do the number two
you have to take the packet and then you
dig there so the place is going to be
full of
all those things you can't go to the
bush
and see it because there are people who
are building their house also
zuleka is convinced that she will
continue to live here the future
a court order for eviction takes up to
one and a half years
the police are not intervening for the
time being and around her
the settlement continues to grow